the thing i've been wondering recently
is that we hentai has become this like
buzz word right where we use it to
describe it
we use like it is to describe anything
that kind of involves like titty or sex
nowadays but
like do you feel like there's a
difference between just hentai
like like porn and like erotica with
like
good like things that have good plots
but also just happen to have sex
yeah yeah absolutely because i think the
whole hentai's hentai's art thing that's
you know
that we kind of promote is that it's
it's it's not so much that
we think that this is like jack-off
material we just think that just because
it has sex in it doesn't necessarily
mean that this is just
you know porn you know that's you guys
not me
well i mean you know like that like it's
like why why does like
a lot of like artistic film use sex as
like a weight oh yeah
that's fine i'm not gonna like bust out
my dick in the cinema when i see a sex
scene yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i think the whole like hentai is odd
yeah yeah stems from like oh it's got
titties in it therefore it's degenerate
the only way the way that i judge it is
if i type in free hentai and the website
like you know has like 10 pop-ups i'm
like this is porn
oh yeah this is porn if if there's not
at least five pop-ups it's probably not
porn
yeah right like i'm not going to like
play [ __ ] [ __ ] wars and be like oh
this is like
yes i love i love the artistic
innovation i feel like if anything it's
just like the
images that get shared on twitter most
of the time they're just artists just
drawing like you know just
stills or something or whatever like
just hot i like those those are nice
those are
yeah like i would never like to get on
the train and get like a chub
at seeing like a twitter art like of
like a sexual oh no no no but it's like
i'm like nice
but i mean you guys would right cause
you read your doujins i mean just a
picture wouldn't be enough
yeah yeah i don't know it takes more
than that
i don't i don't crack a fat every time i
[ __ ] like
every time i'm like oh yeah there's some
lewds let me just like i'm just like
next to the train on joey at rush hour
i'm like joey
i can feel it stop stop watching him you
see me on a pack train just
like liking hentai on my twitter i need
the semen bank of a [ __ ] bull if i
which like if like if i was to jack off
every time i saw a lead on my twitter
timeline
jesus christ because there's so many
loots in your timeline like
you'd be jacking off every like every
other [ __ ] second basically
there's got to be a challenge right it's
like you see a nude on twitter you got a
jackal
you have to finish everything it's like
the opposite of no nothing
only not nervous we've got to like do a
counter movement
i like how this conversation completely
just delved
we should go back to youtube stuff and
sydney's origin story yeah
we'll save for the hentai episode we can
talk about this forever yeah that's like
a straight hour
like is hentai really art
this is the most civilized discussion
we've had on trash days